welcome to this video playing cpu 101 on
from Italy let's let's see what kind of
position we get maybe something was c 5
i'm just taking it that that's quite
uncommon and okay let's get it back okay
it's no ambition to to hold her hold the
pawn which are in a way expected but it
didn't it didn't play that okay and
while this is hanging mmm never just be
6 care maybe how to how to place pieces
here this one to c6 maybe i'm not quite
sure how to how to arrange the pieces he
and the best way yeah that that you can
do nine to d4 it looks quite a bit like
a Sicilian but he has opponent e to
instead of you form can just be six
yeah all that is not really doing much
for white but what he is doing is
playing quickly not wasting any time
okay night is six exchange the d4 night
maybe you know looks like a simple way
to go okay and just just take that no
Bishop to see six maybe now I look
selected looks quite quite normal with
with the b5 coming coming maybe of
course I also don't mind to trade the
bishops here I expected you for actually
ah that's an interesting way to play he
spotted that that he can play 95 at the
end and this that's not so great really
as I cannot move the bishop because of
97 so he will take here damage my pawn
structure that's not very good poor okay
it's not like I'm losing instantly or
something but why does unquestionably
better here
yeah basically the whole sixth-ranked
here f6d 6 b 6 a-6 I think all week so
I'm yeah not brilliant okay I'd like to
disturb him a bit with the possibility
to play an h4 and if he plays h for
himself I go rookie form okay he did not
do anything against that so I'm going to
play that okay so we're going to play h5
on not quite sure I just block this for
the moment and to see how to continue
after that look 21
is it possible Group chief want to cover
the Hedgehog one but in general I don't
mind to have from his King a bit exposed
in general I thought that it would
probably be more dangerous for me if he
just would have tried to play it against
my weaknesses here like these cigs and
so on there is no made on g6 can go
Queen d3 or something but it's not
really not really great on here rook age
five yeah maybe just a tech h4 down to
two minutes
and I can hear i can play something like
that that's true but I have various
amounts of smoke defy for example just
asking wider we are you doing with your
queen queen e for the f5 I think
Queenie for f5s maybe root g6 em down
that's what g 6 so I cannot play that
Queenie for I need to do something else
probably rook h6 am preparing f5 f5
there was robbed g6 takes Queen e7
Edward wins ok yeah but now there is a
five isn't there why not have five here
this isn't this strong white resign it
is strong but I mean strong in making
him resign but he had quinsy form check
so there wasn't the material loss sir it
wasn't unavoidable to news material I
can show you though f5 was not working
because of this film and edge why this
winning with the checkmate evening yeah
here he had rook g one which was strong
yeah rook c5 and this is just a gap just
very good for white yeah maybe this h4
idea wasn't really great them I could
have done some things to printer to
prepare that let's say something like
that why it is always better because of
the pawn structure and you've got to
pawn islands while I have three until
this said this is just everypony's is
somewhat weak and therefore white is
always better with it so needs to be one
can easily lose the advantage of black
gets too active
that's sometimes neglected benefit of
having a worse pawn structure normally
the side with the worst bone structure
has more open files and I have the file
so i can play rupee for i take a form
and try to disturb whites king that's
probably nothing to substantial if why
does some cautious and and and
calculates precisely but still it needs
to be done in a practical game yeah i
would have liked to be white here of
course but still not easy yeah and he
just resigned to very prematurely
alright thanks for watching